the jogan experience but why would you
stop if you're healthy that's a good
point I mean I mean I would I would want
you to stop if I see performance
slipping yeah there's something about uh
there you know when you watch fights as
much as I watch fights and you've seen
certain guys for as long as I see I kind
of have like a
a it's almost like I there's there's I
know what they do so I see them and I
have like a like a mold that I can put
them in so like when I see guys moving
different and I see guys slowing down
and I see guys throwing one two and then
not reacting on the counter shot and not
throwing the counter kicks is his legs
gone is his knees [__] why is he
moving I start to see it and you just
they look kind of the same like the same
guy but in my mind in the mold these
things don't they don't fit anymore so I
go okay there's been a change what about
Izzy's last fight because I don't think
he's
necessarily he looked like that last he
looked like he was stuck in the mud yeah
but I don't know if he's we talked about
that last night we talked about that
last night who that might have been an
is this could be multiple issues it
could be just a weird physical thing
maybe he just woke up and he just didn't
feel good which does happen it would
suck a fat dick if that happened on a
world title fight against a guy who's
been talking mad [__] about you calling
you a [__] for China oh my God but but
it can happen to people where you're
just flat
yeah I'd be curious to see him come back
I know also before we say any of that
Sean Strickland looks so [__] good
yeah it's I don't know if that was Izzy
being flat I it might be that he
underestimated him yeah Chris Curtis
says like all the time people come in
good ass kickboxers come in and Sean
Strickland just frustrates them
pressures them so much doesn't let off
the gas pedal defends all their hard
shots and keeps pressure him he says he
makes a lot of guys look bad like that s
dude I think he's also got that front
kick to the body off the left leg that
people aren't talking about like that
was so important it was so important
because he's standing like this straight
up and you don't know when it's coming
and every now and then he's stabbing you
in the gut and he doesn't throw a lot of
kicks but he throws a very effective
left front kick and his [__] checks
are on the money yeah you could tell it
Izzy like you he could you could almost
hear it even on the TV like he'd land
those stabbing kicks like [__] and that
[__] spars like that so often
that he's composed just another day it's
day he doesn't get tired in the fifth
[__] round he like I was watch his
stomach in between rounds flat just
standing there drinking water flat like
like 50 60 beats a minute I'm like this
is crazy this guy's this guy's calm and
relaxed in the fifth [__] round of
his first world title fight against one
of the greatest of all time a guy who
just dominated and had that incredible
speech yeah you know one time I want you
to feel this one time in your life that
was probably the coolest moment for me
ever when knocked out oh Fu crazy the
arrows come on greatest celebration
fired up greatest celebration of all
time that was good that was you made me
want to cry for him like did you see DC
posted how many UFC's he headlined and
it was [__] insane within like five
six years maybe that had a factor too
maybe it's just an overload factor maybe
takes six months off gets recharged I
was talking to UFC recently and we just
[__] and they're like I he's
constantly same with vinoski asking let
me fight let me fight let me fight let
me fight I asked him I I said you think
he's going to want to chill for a little
bit and they're like [__] no [__] no I
could call him tomorrow and say hey you
want to find MSG you need say yes please
like how much is his five round training
camps changing after the eighth one yeah
do you still [__] do what you did in
the first one go hard over there City
kickboxing that is an amazing gym yeah
Eugene seems a cool [__] [__]
man he's got to be up there with the
greatest [__] man he's so calm and
composed and rational the way he gives
Corner advice the way he talks even in
the postf fight press conference when he
talked about it you know it's like he's
so
composed